Israel Palestine has had a long
complicated history of War conflict and
bloodshed going back decades this is a
subject that needs to be treated with
sensitivity and to be discussed as
calmly and as rationally as possible by
experts who know the history of this
terrible conflict that's why it was so
welcome that Mia Khalifa waited into the
debate because if there's one thing this
situation needs it's a for of por star
voicing her support for hamamass I'm no
Islamic scholar but even I know that
Hamas might not be the biggest fans of
Mia's back catalog I can't imagine
hamash sit down after A Hard Day's
murdering and kidnapping to enjoy teens
love black Cox and big tits round ass's
five and if they do they'd probably keep
it on the download Asama bin Len didn't
advertise the fact that he loved a porno
man as it would dilute the message it's
very difficult to scream about about Jad
and death to the infidels when everyone
knows you're partial to reading the odd
copy of Razzle on the toilet as a
comedian I'm devastated that I'll never
write a joke as good as queer for
Palestine you could put the greatest
comedians of all time in a room and
they'd never write a line as good as
that I'm looking forward to their
offshoots blacks for apartheid and Jews
for Adolf if I was gay the first place I
would move to would be an Islamic
theocracy why wouldn't you want to live
in countries that endorse gay men being
thrown off buildings although the
Israelis have solved that problem
because pretty soon there will be no
buildings left in Palestine BLM came out
and were as principled and moderate as
they always are BLM Chicago tweeted a
picture of a Hass paraglider with the
words I stand with Palestine it's almost
like they weren't the good guys there's
nothing wrong with the words I stand
with Palestine just maybe don't tweet it
after a massacre of civilians and
probably leave out the image of the
terrorist paragliders who committed the
massacre as that just might upset people
one of the leaders of Hamas lives in a
council flat in London this is an
absolute disgrace if the leader of a
hugely corrupt International Terror
organization can't afford to buy his own
place you know the housing crisis really
is out of control what's the point of
rising to the very top of your field
orchestrating attacks that murder
thousands of innocent civilians if you
can't afford a nice little twoed in sh
ditch this country's gone to the dogs
where's the incentive to work hard there
have been demonstrations every Saturday
in London ever since a terrorist attack
in Israel the far right say we want our
country back sld the country I want my
city back I want to be able to buy an
overpriced coffee and give passive
aggressive stink ey to slow Walkers
without having entire sections of my
city blocked off while people chant from
the river to the Sea if you chant from
The River To The Sea you have an IQ of
43 stop chanting slogans that you don't
understand just cuz it Rhymes doesn't
mean it's good Pro Palestine protesters
accosted Michael Gove the minister for
housing Enchanted shame on you for not
doing something about Gaza he can't even
get a few Council Flats built and you
think he's going to sort out the Middle
East that's like asking an insult to
lose his virginity in a gang bang There
were also a sign ific element of these
protesters with anti-semitic placards
chanting openly racist slogans things
got so ugly that at one point it looked
like the labor Party Conference Jeremy
Corbin even turned up reminding us of
the Glory Days of the 2019 general
election and that 32% Landslide one man
even openly praised Hitler Hitler knew
how to deal with this people as we all
know Adolf didn't like the Jews but I
doubt he'd be a massive fan F of Muslims
either I'm sure he wouldn't look at a
mosque and think H now there's a group
of people I like and respect apart from
their attitude to the Jews and in that
respect they'd get on like a synagogue
on fire we also had football Hooligans
turning up to defend the statues as a
child of the'80s in South London it was
quite comforting to see my old Nextdoor
neighbors indulging in what they do best
channeling their rage at their divorce
into beating up the police I want the
number of hamas's PR guy whoever does
their PR is a genius imagine staging an
attack that kills and injures thousands
of innocent civilians and their millions
of people celebrate you for being
Freedom Fighters I need that guy to sell
my next tour everything and everyone is
now political I'm half expecting to
click on PornHub and see a banner that
says we stand with Israel of course
that's a joke PornHub a pro BLM there's
no way you can be both Pro BLM and
pro-israel Israel are oppressors for
burning Gaza to the ground while BLM are
heroes for setting Portland on fire in
2020 during the height of the summer of
2020 PornHub recorded a porn film where
one of the actresses in The throws of
ecstasy moaned B LM maybe in 2023 they
can show support for the Middle East by
employing an actress with a great set of
Tel avives who has a nicely trimmed Gaza
Strip moaning that she wants a man to
touch her BB Netanyahu the police have
lost their minds too when asked why they
won't arrest people calling for Jihad in
the street they explain that Jihad has
many meanings basically they have no
idea what Jihad is which is
understandable given they have no idea
what a criminal is either in London you
can pretty much do what you want as a
criminal provided you don't misgender
someone on Twitter the only way they're
going to catch a sex offender is if they
employ them the police also covered
themselves in Glory by employing an
advisor they led the chance of from The
River To The Sea Palestine will be free
many people have found this offensive I
however am delighted that the Met have
appointed someone with a high enough IQ
that they're able to learn a rhyme spur
a thought for the ordinary person in all
of this who now has to pretend to know
what he's talking about when it comes to
this sensitive topic and by person I of
course mean men there's no way any
self-respecting male can say the words I
don't know and any type of conversation
you need to be able to give a measured
well-informed opinion on every topic
whether it's the Middle East what type
of dementia Joe Biden has and which
transwoman you'd have sex with Monroe
bergd off in the past few years we've
had to become experts on brexit
epidemiology virology Immunology Russian
politics and now this I miss a days when
all we had to know about was football
and got a round of applause for being
able to correctly identify what emotion
we were feeling now unless you know the
intimate details of Benjamin netanyahu's
sock draw and what type of mole he eats
before launching Rockets then you're a
heartless Bard who doesn't care about
people's suffering wo beide you if you
have Jewish leftwing friends or you have
a pro Palestinian girlfriend you'll have
to get your story straight for both
parties if you want to avoid an argument
or get laid you can't wear a Palestinian
flag to your Jewish mate's birthday but
if you wear in Harvard then you might
well hook up with a student who's Pro
Palestine and believes it's sex work is
real work and what's really important in
this brutal conflict are the lives of
Palestinian trans women so remember to
be on the right side of History wear
your mask take your booster put your
pronouns in your bio and wave your
Palestinian flag in the air like you
just don't care just be aware of your
surroundings otherwise you will be asked
to leave the synagogue before you go let
me take a minute to recommend a
longevity supplement by Verso in our
recent interview with Tim Urban he said
this about longevity we should be
talking about longevity and Longevity
science researchers like the biologist
David Sinclair have recently made some
fascinating discoveries on how to
mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and that's why I am using
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these incredible scientific
breakthroughs into products that hold
the potential to increase your longevity
and one of their products that I take
every day is called cell beinging cell
beinging helps combat aging by
increasing something called NAD Plus in
your body now NAD is arguably the most
important molecule in your body high NAD
levels improve your metabolism repairs
damaged DNA and increases energy
production in your brain immune system
and muscles but as you grow old your
body's NAD levels go down and you can't
take NAD as a supplement because it's
too big for your cells to absorb that's
why Verso cell being contains nmn
Resveratrol and TMG these three
molecules work together to increase NAD
plus levels if you want to read more
about this check out the scientific
research Linked In the description of
this video plus Verso publishes third
party testing on every batch of its
products to guarantee that you're
getting exactly what you're paying for
so if you want to join me you can get
15% off by going to
b.so that's
v.o and use code trigger to save 15% off
your order and if you've enjoyed this
video watch me take down woke Hollywood
[Music]
here